Zeke Roden what have you done in your
life that you will never do again I will
never again deliberately go to a Country
Music Festival in rural Wisconsin unless
you have a penchant for confederate
flags cheese curds and absolutely
horrific music that is not a place that
i recommend going confederate flags in
Wisconsin yeah that's something I would
think about yeah rural Wisconsin you
they've got the Confederate flag they've
got the whole thing going on there at
these I went I got roped into going to a
country music festival that lasted three
days now I didn't camp out
I had a hotel nearby and I thought how
bad can it be it's just hanging out at a
festival right like how how bad how
horrible could the music and people
really be that it would ruin my stay and
it was absolutely horrifying and I would
never ever do that again on purpose if
there was some reason why I had to do it
I guess I you know listen I would choose
that over an invasive medical procedure
for sure but it's not something I would
I would look for yeah I think of music
festivals as just camping with things to
do right you know you can be loud check
out the acts you can do all the
different festivities right give us the
list of all the things that you do with
these music festivals like I don't think
I would be able to okay the FCC
compliant probably a story for a
different day so listen I'm never doing
that again
not on purpose and also I am never again
having alcohol and coffee at elevation
and I figured out I about a year a
little over a year ago I fainted on an
airplane
after having both a glass of wine and
espresso and had the low blood pressure
incident and then in Argentina about two
months ago in the pre Andes area so like
not the high Andes but at about four or
five thousand feet I went to a wine
lunch and had a couple glasses of wine
and then of course as is commonly the
case in Argentina and in many other
countries you have an espresso after the
fact and again I didn't faint but I
started feeling like I was going to pass
out and I was able to lay down and
recover and it's abundantly clear that
in thinner atmospheres where there is
less oxygen I guess is what I mean I
should not be combining alcohol with
coffee that I have a sensibility to that
and sensitivity maybe the right word is
so I am NOT going to be doing that again
no more Bailey's before skydiving either
you gotta cut that out - that's exactly
right and of course I don't drink
Bailey's and I've never sky go though so
hopefully that one doesn't come up but
yeah just that's another thing I'm not
going to be doing again anything you
have on the list here I'll probably
never take a 1997 chevrolet express van
with 220,000 miles on it cut across the
country right yes that's the one and
done that's that's a once-in-a-lifetime
and you've learned your lesson
experience do we know the fate of the
van did it get dropped off at a chop
shop er no it's still alive I think it
starts maybe one out of five attempts
okay so yeah too bad I guess next time
what you'll rent a car for a trip like
that yeah I mean the exhaust leak power
steering motor failure
none of these stuff help I recently
drove a car that's along anyway this is
why I'm not even gonna get up anyway I
recently experienced after many years of
being accustomed to modern power
steering I drove a car that barely had
power steering and it's really not fun
if you're gonna work out is it is it's
quite a work I am